so you also have man College
indoctrination it's not as bad as a lot
of people would say it is okay there are
a lot of professors who are nuts but
there's there's there's been a couple
surveys that found that in certain
humanities political fields it's
definitely bad really really bad yeah
but there's a lot of stuff that's not
you know people people kind of
exaggerate things to a certain degree
yeah I mean it go ahead no you get hot
press on the on the you know really
extreme cases mm-hmm but but it it is to
a certain degree indoctrinating people
making them think insane things so you
put them in this machine that tells them
communism actually isn't all that bad
and they graduate now now think about
what happens you spend 22 years or so
not 22 years but you know you start
school what five so 17 years in an
institutionalized learning facility you
graduated 22 every step of the way
there's been an authority figure
providing everything for you you go to
school there's the cafeteria the food's
right there you walk right up you take
it's all part of your meal plan mm-hmm
then you graduate and you're sitting
there thinking okay where's where's my
food where's the nurse where's the lunch
lady to give me my food yeah government
government cheese please hey you know
what I just realized
what you know the reason that school is
so expensive is because it's subsidized
right as the government is paying for
those schools that's why they jack up
the prices like that and then they offer
to forgive your loans and then people
graduate and they're like Oh where's the
government to help me pay my bills and
then you have to wonder what they were
thinking by subsidizing this education
that made them think the government was
a good thing
I know hold on before we move I want us
to say you you said something about
basically them going yeah yeah it's a
communist system like hmm all right I'm
kind of interested in that yeah but now
we're fine now I've we've we've talked
about this a couple times that China is
working with professors paying them
under the radar here that huge story
today what like millions of dollars to a
Harvard professor each got busted boom
and and I'm sitting to find it there
Communist Party they want us to be
fractured they want what's happening
right now in our country that's what
they want they want us fractured they
want our youth going against us to split
us up this is exactly what China wants
right now two hours ago top Harvard
professor indicted in
chyna case Wow they say dr. Charles
Lieber 61 will be arraigned in federal
court in Boston on two counts of making
false statements to investigators
regarding his involvement in China's
thousand towns plans so when was that
case do you know I thought it was a
while ago oh this guy he was okay so
this yeah okay he was arrested on
January 28th so this is the same guy but
the story is they just made it happen oh
so he was officially indicted now yeah
right right so it's a it's a part of
that ongoing story yeah yeah they've
been doing this yep they got their
little tendrils in in everything yes
they do well you know what man how is
this not a main main thing like I was
still shocked I'm still shocked that
throughout the whole coronavirus thing
no woody no mainstream media talked
about how we found Chinese nationalists
bringing in coronavirus yeah that was
four years yeah I'm I am still kind of
like when I think about him like wow
that's really kind of gross but not a
bigger story how is that not a big story
exactly it's almost like there's you
know some group that doesn't want anyone
to know about is trying to involvement
because Jeff Zucker at CNN is a reality
TV guy and he's sitting there and going
like what do I care about this story run
run run from yeah right right right run
Trump Trump Trump what do you get Ducati
we got caught today eating a cream puff
from a local bakery yeah can we make
that racist somehow and then and then
when guy goes like whoa cream puffs
white on the inside oh oh we can make it
like a secret racist thing yeah and also
has a story and it's like Trump dog
whistle to neo-nazis eats cream puffs
yeah I kid you not it's like your
rhiness you're like puff gate secretly
inside the beige part treat is white
cream that proves it orange on the
outside way do you see the story where
they were like Trump saltshaker was
bigger no there was a picture and they
were like two salt as a salt salt pepper
shaker uh-huh and they were different
one was like rectangular one was
circular yeah the one by Trump was
bigger than the one not by Trump yeah
and he loves himself he loves its men
show up whatever I don't even care
anymore also the president you like a
certain set right
no no no well that wouldn't surprise me
if there was a little tea on it
no that would surprise me you know what
was likely what the person came in and
put some salt shakers on the table and
left yeah and Trump was eaten and they
were like what can we do what can we do
look okay picture that's salt it looks
bigger it's bigger
I remember the infamous two scripts two
scoops of ice cream store you remember
that no Trump gets two scoops of ice
cream and everyone else gets one I'm not
joking CNN did that story and to be fair
enn did a story on him getting two
scoops yes everyone else has one yes
they did now hold on to be fair it was
supposed to be like a silly segment but
it got honestly picked up then before my
Awakening nightmare world and this is
what they were covering instead of China
sneaking in literal living viruses in
unand unmarked vials yeah hidden and
they caught the guy and he lied he said
like no I don't have anything and
they're like whoa we just found these
vials on you like oh well those I'm
bringing to a professor at one of your
universities they think about think
about the news reports that could have
been breaking news America yeah Chinese
national has been detained in relation
to smuggling of viruses into this
country without proper permits yeah
local security you know security experts
are concerned Mobile instead we got
breaking news America the president
received two scoops of ice cream and
they were they were metal white and and
then they start talking about how like
the Democrats got chocolate vanilla
swirl which shows how they're all very
interested in ending racism yeah and
then you have and then you have two
hours of pundits being like listen you
don't understand the dog whistle that is
Trump getting vanilla so or let me
explain to you this thing only I can
hear and then and then other person's
like no you're wrong the vanilla swirl
isn't a dog whistle its overt he's
saying straight up the argument is
actually not about whether it is or
isn't racist it's that it is of course
but the the connotations are different
now Nancy Pelosi what she got chocolate
vanilla swirl
I think
shows real leadership in this country
and it's like it's like Trump didn't
even choose the ice cream it was just
like some guy to tray and then they were
handing him out he's like thank you and
then they're like hmm he accepted it
there's literally nothing you can do so
you have seven n-nothing I'm imagining
Jeff Zucker he's sitting in a room and
he's looking at two folders and he's
like mmm and it says like China
smuggling and viruses with you know and
and hiring researchers to steal research
orange man bad folder it's the guy in
the mud yeah yeah yeah he's sweating no
no it's not no it's not fair no sweat at
all just smile yeah smile and wink as he
presses orange man bed right somewhat no
okay here's a better analogy they had
them two folders and he looks at the
orange man banding us her those put this
put the cigar around the nose dude when
he goes all right it's all angry when he
sees and he throws the the China
reported papers flying everywhere don't
you ever bring that my office again we
don't want any that garbage this doesn't
click rate enough come on what is what
do we look like a news organization that
ended in the 90s I don't know where we
are now it's a bunny trail something
about Harvard the Harvard guy schools
you said China got into Harvard and then
we started talking about how it was well
not Harvard just schools in general yeah
maybe we'll go to war with China and
this law justice beer you know why you
keep saying it I keep starting to
believe it through Citadis trap man did
you imagine if like they reinstate rain
stood the draft and then like that
eighteen year old woman in the free zone
would be like drafted equality yeah
no it is kind of weird that they were
talking about the draft again like a
month ago like they keep doing it like
why what what you know you know people
don't realize is that you know when it
came to Vietnam
mmm-hmm the draft was complete BS yeah
and I can understand why they were like
okay we can't do that again but if we're
talking about a real existential threat
now there's me a draft man two seconds
China with their one point four billion
people how many people are in billions
1.3 billion people
yep how many we got 300 million
three hundred thirty million yeah
they'll be they'll be conscription in
two seconds man yeah did you imagine you
this is what's crazy about these like
wacko lefties what they really want them
you don't want these revolutionary
wackos to have guns they're not gonna
take orders well they're not smart
well we already we saw that we talked
about it yesterday that he was was the
unactive duty ya know if he was he was
on active duty so there was someone on
active duty went on a rampage killed
some cops killed some guys well he
killed one cop for sure okay we don't
know if he did another two and yeah
Oakland ders knows one other cop in
Oakland Oh shot someone show them they
think it may have been him cuz he had a
van with weapons in it mmm-hmm but yeah
they're not gonna want these people so
then what do we do it's like we're
falling apart from the inside man our
military is half the size of China's
just for the record yeah but we got we
got we got a better tech we got we got
UFO Tech yeah not made in China but you
know by oh man you're a foe Tech I'm
willing to bet a lot of people don't
want to believe it but I'm willing to
bet that we've got military tech you
could not even imagine absolutely sure
totally
cuz there's a really funny story I was
reading when I was worried about these
UFOs and it was talking about how
they're these weird sightings for UFOs
in certain areas and go and they
passively mentioned it was only like you
know 50 miles away from a naval
experimental Technology Center it's like
what like oh well 2+2 is that like
you've replace sodoku it's like I can
see I can see what's happening here man
you got a crazy flying ship military
military research center yeah it is very
complicated it wasn't hard for people
but I people still want to claim they
probably made the space force just to
like allocate more budget to the tech
that they need to work on if look when
we hear about the weapons they make like
I think six seven years ago they created
a new streamlined of gravity bomb I'm
not good a Megaton nuke that was very
small because blocking the original was
massive yeah and so they figured how to
do it better and you know more compact
and interesting you just dropped out of
a plane but we got ICBMs man we got
crazy weapons and that stuff's all what
from the 70s how old is that stuff
that's pretty old yeah if you think
they're not working on better ways to
kill yeah and and if you think that the
ones they're working on
now they're telling you all about I
don't buy it man I think there are
certain certain things for immediate
visible use and they're keeping their
races up their sleeve I think the US has
got some crazy stuff
don't hit for sure a lot of cyber
assignments how much money do does the
US military spend every year can you
look that up a very big honor it's gotta
be a lot yeah crazy amount yeah I mean
there's a good argument that bureaucracy
is miserable and fails all the time
yeah but I'm not gay man look on her
face I saw the number for the US
military spending per year hold on wait
wait wait in 2018 they say in the
department of defense appropriations
bill it was six hundred and seventeen
billion dollars for the base budget and
another 69 billion for war funding Wow
I'd say we are prepared that is lots of
dollars many dollars a lot of money
yeah yeah and then and then you think
about they build these tanks they valves
weapons and then they rear and then it
gets reappropriation sand stuff then
people get mad about it yeah but man I I
don't think we could be invaded to be
honest when you got like a small town of
like 300 people and they've literally
got armored personnel carriers with like
machine guns Mountain I'm not kidding
it's like an actual video is watching
weird mom yeah it's like I think they're
good but that's hand-me-down stuff true
what what is what is the u.s. hiding up
its sleeve like a lot of money a parent
listen listen they didn't just come out
and say to the world like we're building
a nuclear bomb yeah
Manhattan Project was a secret they can
do the same thing today you as
compartmentalised you wouldn't know what
you were working on well an American
made products are they usually last a
chinese-made stuff tends to break more
often I mean it is the stuff they're
giving us so are they making good
quality stuff for themselves yeah no you
don't think so no man it's let's low
quality because the people are basically
slaves you know they walk off buildings
and mess who is that it's horrifying
yeah that's true yeah we shouldn't be
supporting it it's funny because I've
heard a lot of arguments about like
sweatshop labor okay
and the argument from the pro sweatshop
people is there are no jobs where they
live and this gets them substantially
more money than they could have made
otherwise even if it
dirt even if it's a quarter per hour
yeah that's still you know they normally
make like a penny per hour Wow so to
them it's like this is amazing
yeah and I'm like I still don't think
it's a good idea I'm greedy I mean I get
the argument it creates jobs and
Industry and all that stuff but why
don't you just pay them better and
actually benefit the area but in the end
just hire Americans like we got the
outsourcing thing was a big disaster for
us yeah I agree I don't I don't know
their plan was I guess the plan was like
make America the educated elite class
well we don't yet middle city don't need
like hundred pairs of of shirts you know
or jeans you know we you know it's like
I have a pair of jeans that I've been
wearing for ten years they're great they
still they're good shape I just got I
just bought a new pair of pants built in
America guaranteed for life so if
anything happens I can send it back to
the company and they fix them for me and
send it back to me so I just got a pair
of shorts for them I'm stoked that's the
kind of stuff I like we don't need you
know it's funny I was a model for a long
time modeling clothes to sell clothes
and after I left that industry I'm kind
of disgusted by it because it kind of I
helped it you know essentially
fast-fashion become more of a thing like
people go buy more stuff this is look at
this new outfit you need this new thing
and it's like even and it just got worse
and worse and worse quality over time
and wasn't good quality stuff this is
one of the biggest problems I have a
capitalism nother thing there's more the
biggest problem with capitalism is that
it
humans are incentivized to produce and
consume things that lead us to horrible
ends you know you know so I think I
mentioned this in the show before
there's a quote by a physicist or
whatever that if humans ever meet aliens
they'll shake hands not because they
overcame the nuclear bomb but because
they overcame the Xbox yeah meaning that
in in a capitalist system
humans are driven to their baser
instincts and they keep buying new
things they get fat they eat terrible
food they become sedentary and they play
video games and they whack off all that
however mmm-hmm just because I have a
problem with the system it doesn't mean
I think communism you know would be the
alternative and that's what a lot of
these activists think sure they're like
we consume too much
communism I'm like no no
do anything it's not even about that all
of these big natural disasters
you know like Chernobyl and stuff no
it's ineffective competition works
yeah competition gives I mean the space
race we went to the moon because of
competition you know it does give us a
reason to you know better ourselves so
there needs to be some kind of a balance
between you know the solution is
cultural I saw the look on your face the
solution is problem is cultural okay
Elon Musk needs to launch a rocket to
Mars and inspire everybody to be like I
want to be cool
I want space stuff yeah right now
everyone's like I want 57 of the
different shirts with different logos
this is got a body on it this one's got
a giraffe on it yeah and then it's just
a bunch of waste product that doesn't do
anything to make society but I mean he
just launched two people into space cup
- exactly exactly it was amazing I cried
a little bit watching Evan and we
measured up it was awesome
we need an ambitious private company
right right best part to me yeah yeah
that's crazy huh so it's a first and
that was an investment project right
like they were doing a test what so that
was there was a test run right well no
no they've tested it that was their
maiden voyage what basically were they
when they came to do it oh my question
yeah like the US government paid them to
serve the payload yes absolutely yeah
that they were NASA astronauts sent a
why so much less to do it that way
though boom nailed it significantly so
yeah what can we do for young kids
growing up to have them strive to focus
not on stupid consumerism but focus on
projects that make awesome new things so
that's one of the big challenges we have
right now is it's not capitalism
capitalism creates rapid competition and
rapid expansive growth yeah it can be
good it's only bad if we don't get off
this planet if we can get off earth and
we find better means of propulsion and
then we're talking about capitalism
being a godsend yeah one of the big
complaints is like we consume too much
what it what gratitude Berg say your
fairy tales of endless economic growth
yes yeah well we start mining asteroids
and colonizing other planets it will be
unless as far as we can tell
yeah till we get out there yeah I don't
think she
that we can't go back we can't go back
to you know everyone owning a farm and
it being like 1500s you know it's like
that's not the way it is anymore we are
a technological society we are only
advancing we have to figure out how how
to make it work with our society dude
these people they want to destroy the
system they want you living in a cave
you know like that woman that 18 year
old free Seattle you know the woman
who's part of the free Capitol Hill
whatever they seize this this 7 block
radius right want to destroy
civilization that's amazing
ok it's like you have no idea how
comfortable you have been for your 18
years on this planet man little little
miss little day little they get eaten by
a wild boar in like 20 minutes
yeah could you imagine it work or stub
your toe yeah you're dead and get it's
like Wow medicines yeah it's like I
stubbed my toe
OOP it's bleeding I'm gonna die yes yes
all day that is yeah yeah and and and
antibiotic resistance there's a lot of
things that are threatening our
wonderful way of life you know we gotta
keep striving to improve I'll also point
out to with that statement she made
about endless economic growth it's like
you can have economic growth in a
virtual reality yeah exactly
so yeah so there's a lot of there's a
lot of new jobs that emerge in weird
ways like wow world of warcraft of gold
farming yeah yeah I mean you do that
right no no what what did you you uh no
no I manipulated the market yeah that's
the game but there were people whose job
in China was literally to go around just
grinding in a video game
yeah to generate currency so the players
could buy it from them well back when I
was playing Diablo 2 that was a thing
too that people would set up websites
where you can buy go buy an item
whatever item you want and they would
meet up with you in a game and trade it
to you and yeah it's like there are
weird jobs expensive stuff too now I'm
not afraid I'm not a fan of that no look
it's it's no know what I mean it's like
it's fun I don't care that it exists
Gaming is fun yeah I'm just saying
pater win think about how many people on
this planet working right in United
States ignore the pandemic stuff yeah we
had record low unemployment but what are
the humans doing
I would prefer it if all of the humans
were building spaceships however I know
that if all humans stopped their work
and then started working on spaceships
the entire system would collapse because
you need more than spaceships to survive
yeah we're not automated yet yet well
it's not the issue the issue is in order
to make you know the the polymers for
the ship you need this industry this
industry that industry right all of this
different work together creates all of
these different unique things that's
true look the problem with communists is
is that they're like okay stop
production on the food and start
building a nuclear power plant and like
okay and then they'll starve that that's
what capitalism is better it's a
decentralized system that allocates
resources where they're needed when
they're needed and if it can't support
itself it it goes extinct yeah the big
challenge though is overcoming our baser
instincts which to an extent I'm fine
with you want to have a sugary can of
soda like I got right here you wanna
have a chocolate cake or go for it mm-hm
but how do we convince more of our
economic energy to go towards awesome
stuff new new energies space travel can
we do better so people aren't you know
spending all their time making 50
billion different t-shirts like could
you imagine how stupid would be if
there's like a teacher that said spin
the UFO or just like a picture of me
saying harrumph
I'm kidding by the way pick up your Tim
cast IRL sure in the description below
I'm actually I'm actually only half
kidding I I do think it's like we have a
bunch of stuff we don't need
right and within reason it's fine but I
think we need a cultural shift towards
cool projects like like the space race
was yeah we're little kids we're looking
for the sky going wow yeah and then
dreaming of being an astronaut working
at NASA well honey these movies kind of
killed that we're so spoiled with it's
like yeah cool space whatever that's
like yeah but space you realize what's
out there it's not I don't think it's
the movies I think it's you want kids to
look up to somebody mm-hmm so if when
you have a little kid in front of you
and you go wow look at outer space they
don't know better they're gonna bec okay
outer space good know if you sit around
the TV you know your mom is crying your
dad's waving a little American flag and
you're a little kid watching this you
know this this rocket take off
that kid is being told this is what gets
me approval this is what I must do
so that people like me that's being
replaced now by whoa cancel culture
nonsense where they're like I'll get
followers if I call you a Nazi yeah so
we need to get a get off of that stuff
you know it's true move towards
inspiring people to invent things and to
travel and get into you know Sciences
and not even not even that methodologies
are important as technologies better
ways to do things otherwise we will just
eat ourselves to death
yeah wither and die yeah we'll be like
yeast in a bottle you know eventually we
consume everything and then you know
nothing left it just dies off I'm
confident though I mean wow it's nice to
see that side of you know I'm so look
humans have been around for a while and
it's in the past like our growth and
Technology advancement as it has been
exponential yeah and the more people
there are the more things we produce the
more things we can produce the more
specialties will exist so I think
certainly the u.s. right now is in
serious trouble mm-hmm but I think
humans for the most part are going to do
crazy things at the very least I imagine
we will probably create some kind of
self-replicating AI that can you know
colonize the universe because that one
ship can just be floating endlessly for
10,000 years
land on a planet adequate resources
replicate replicate replicate and then
whatever it is that we are created
something that does something for some
reason I think that might be a little
naive because what's the point of rapid
self-replication yeah maybe it just
seeds life maybe like these little
vessels will just stop and then drop
some organic matter and then boom a new
planet seeded with life that's what our
legacy will be maybe that's what we we
were you know would it be crazy anyway
enough craziness unless you wanted to
add something well I should why I wanted
to I there's I could talk about space
all day long I was I wanted to bring up
one article but I'd rather I'd rather
bring up a bunch I couldn't I couldn't
bring it up because you got to do the
your little trick oh it's because of
this this thing did I get it did you get
it I think I got it I'm just gonna here
click to this article so I'm just gonna
read a little bit here there's an
article about basically private space
companies SpaceX Blue Origin Virgin
Galactic but there's one thing in here
that I really love and here we go it's
it's basically them talking about when
they go into space and and there's an
effect that happens it's called the
overview effect and I'll read it here it
says you see something something
fundamental changes in you forever once
you've seen the planet in its natural
habitat of space it's called the
overview effect a term coined by Frank
white in 1987 this is a permanent
cognitive shift in awareness experienced
by astronauts you don't see national
boundaries from orbit you don't see
others or races you see humanity as a
whole you see us you see a living
breathing fragile orb filled with
variety of total totally interdependent
living creatures and you see each as
unique fragile and precious you can't
unknowing you can't unfilled it now
there's something so special about that
I love it you know I I don't know what
that feels like to be floating above
earth looking down but I can understand
it
and I mean I've I love space everything
you know if you follow me on Twitter you
you know half of my tweets are just
space related stuff and there's
something about this that I love I I
want more people to feel that way you
know to get that kind of a feeling and
we need it we need that overview affect
people it's it's kind of maybe empathy a
little bit for others you know in the
same same kind of vibe I think that
effect could actually be dangerous
really yeah oh how so take someone who's
got communist type leanings okay and
they're not politically active mm-hmm
they just think man would it be like we
wouldn't just make sense to put a
homeless people in houses like that's so
dumb now take them up the space and look
down on the planet now they have this
feeling where they're like this is you
know this this this feeling they have
could potentially activate them into a
department to say is there are a lot of
people who might be really really dumb
who get inspired by that feeling seeing
the earth as one and then involving
themselves in matters they should not be
involved in okay they lack the ability
the skill the intelligence the
understanding and then they see this and
they're like we all are we are all one
we must you know practive lanit
so precious and and connected and they
become you know some kind of weird
lefty GW bill terrorist or something
yeah yes I'm like that too yeah I see it
you know I understand it's crazy though
man we it really is true we are people
don't realize we are not freely
independent creatures just walking
around doing our thing yeah it's
fascinating to me I was reading about
the discovery of air yet has that ever
occurred to you like that people had to
discover air because twisting that air
exists yeah around us because to a human
there you can't see anything
right and you could only kind of feel
wind and before they understood that
there was actually something with mass
here like we're in an atmosphere right
to them it was like there was nothing
there and so I was reading about how it
got discovered it was because they had
these these like brass balls with holes
in them and a tube that would come out
and you put your thumb you dip it in
water put your thumb over the end and
pull it out and the water stays and then
you put it off your head to shower right
okay so there's one dude was like let me
put my finger my thumb over the hole and
then put it in and see if the water
fills up sure enough it didn't and he
was like there must be something in
there blocking the water and that's and
they realize like air is this tangible
thing let's go so it's like the reason I
bring that up is people often don't
think about we are we're swimming in an
atmosphere
it's just gaseous it's like it could be
water it could be any other medium but
we are in this like big like puddle
basically yeah the air we breathe comes
from trees algae those other things
without them we die we don't get our
food we really are connected to
everything in this ecosystem yeah we are
what's really cool about being smart is
that we created suits that allow us to
leave this and you know go into other
places and stuff it'll be really cool if
we could make a biodome in a ship thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you